we are with carlo wrestler who is the
croatian member of the european
parliament newly elected by the way just
in May this guy looks like he could be a
teenager samam 29 years old
Karla welcome to the show it must be
very exciting to see chess happening
here in Zagreb in Croatian hi hi to
everyone it's really very exciting to
see that and I'm really pleased that it
is happening here in Zagreb in my
hometown and also in Croatia I'm glad
that it's happening now in the beginning
of the touristic season and I'm really a
fan of chess so I'm glad because of that
but also because it's also one of the
nice ways to promote Croatia and to
promote everything we can offer
absolutely you yourself you told me
you're a fan of the game your
grandfather taught you that's right I
started the playing chess when I was
around 6 years old
unfortunately I didn't develop in some
of the grandmasters but I really loved
the game and really enjoying enjoying
seeing it here in Zagreb passing you
know now to your children as well what's
the benefit of chess to young people I'm
also trying to pass the game to to my
children to my daughter who is now
around the age of 5 I really think it
helps a lot to focus and it really gives
you some of the advantages later in your
life because that focus but also that
motivation can really help you in other
areas as well now you have this amazing
position in the European Parliament I
know you have to push all kinds of
important things but we think chess is
important what's the chances that you
approached chess into the European Union
I was elected now with the this year's
elections for the European Parliament in
May and now it's the beginning of the
five years mandate in the European
Parliament I'll definitely give my best
to promote chess also in Strasbourg and
in Brussels in the premises of the
European Parliament but also to do
everything I can also from that position
to promote chess here in Croatia well I
mean you're a big dog now you got to get
it done
we're holding you to try alright well we
appreciate the time you spend with us
coming in making the first move and
passing it on to the children and into
the European Parliament thank you so
much thanks a lot Carl Ressler we expect
big things from him he's promising he's
gonna make Ches happen all over Europe
thank you